happy Christmas time twelve days of
Christmas is now officially over so
congratulations to the winners we picked
you out and here are the winners big one
winner is @j hi ash
hi hey C underscore one one three day
two it is
Nats ng day three winners Lauren hay day
for winner is Cornelius convinces /
under tag hashtag what's under tag D 5
winner is Monica Lou day 6 winner is
Sebastiaan Garcia or Sebastian Garcia
congratulations
day 7 winner is Carolyn day 8 winner is
Tanya I so wrecker I don't know if I
said that right with congratulation day
9 winner is Vivian lamb day 10 is David
pause POV hey 11
congratulations Lisa McEwen just kidding
Lee said mine
congratulations claim your prize day 12
winner is shine naquin thank you guys
this is officially over hopefully you
guys had a lot of fun we will be sliding
into the DMS of the winners and we will
be mailing off the packages in the first
two weeks of January stay tuned because
it will keep doing these giveaways yeah
[Music]
we'll do that surprise over there